hi there steve kaufman here
today i
um
you know i just watched uh president
trump and uh president macron of france
do their press conference
in paris
and i want to talk about why we learn
languages in that context
um
i was tremendously impressed with
first of all president macron who was
able to speak very comfortably in
english
and then at least one
if my memory serves me correctly french
journalist
who was able to ask questions in french
and in english
i am sure that amongst the american
journalists who were there at least
those that are resident in france not
necessarily those that came over from uh
from the u.s following
president trump i am sure that there
were people there who could have asked
questions in french and i wish they
would have it would have been very nice
to hear them ask a question in english
of president trump and ask a question in
french of president macron
and and i always get a wonderful feeling
when i hear people speaking well in
another language doesn't have to be
english it can be any other language and
i have a
a sense of
i would say
power
um
[Music]
sense of achievement when i'm able to
communicate in another language it's a
different level of enjoyment than when i
just speak my own language
and
so it's interesting but today i had two
uh interviews that i did uh for other
people who have web pages or communities
and they wanted to talk to me about
language learning and one of the
questions i was given was
uh going forward given the the
technological change that has happened
and that has affected language learning
in the last
20 years what do i see going forward and
do i think that language learning
as such will become obsolete because
people have something implanted in their
ear and they can just converse in
different languages
and i said i don't think that'll happen
i think the role of teachers is changing
because of the technology we have more
independent language teachers
i think learners are more independent
yet they still require the help of of
teachers to move them along
but that and therefore all of this is
making language learning easier and
therefore i think that
that
the new role of teachers and the
technology that's available is going to
make people learn languages more quickly
more easily
and therefore more people will learn
languages because
the joy is accessing
this other world reading listening
speaking sitting down over
a cup of coffee with someone and
conversing comfortably in another
language understanding more about them
and their culture or
simply in an event like this press
conference
uh
you know if you're not everyone's going
to be the president of france or the
president of the united states but
imagine that the president of the united
states there
were able to answer a question in french
i mean they have simultaneous
interpreters
i just find that that whole environment
is so
um
stimulating
and rewarding
that people will want to do that people
will want to
have that sense of achievement of having
learned another language being able to
use it being able to communicate in it
and just having some
technology that enables you to
communicate
is not going to do it
i think if you're going as i said in my
interview if you're going to croatia
rather than buying a phrasebook you
might buy some or you might have some
app that enables you to order a beer
but
uh you know the fact that we have four
by four altering
vehicles and stuff has not meant that
there's less interest in hiking
uh in fact we have hiking and we have
mountain bikes and we have so many other
ways in which people enjoy
getting into the um
you know the wilderness
and similarly with languages the more
the easier it becomes to learn languages
the more
uh enjoyable the language learning uh
process becomes as people are able to
use the various different apps and
resources on the internet to more easily
interact with
uh foreign languages and learn these
languages more people are going to learn
them more people are going to taste the
sense of achievement they get from
learning other language more people are
going to taste the rewards of speaking
another language and so i think that
technology is going to make language
learning more
popular and
we learn languages all of us for
different reasons
but the more we get into other languages
the more we appreciate
the the value of having other languages
and so to the extent that technology
makes all of that easier i don't think
technology is going to replace the need
for learning other languages it's only
only going to make it more widespread so
people won't be able to say you have a
talent for languages and i don't in fact
all the tools are there even now
and i think more so going into the
future so that everyone can learn and
enjoy
the feeling of speaking in other
languages
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you